Bonjour.
J'aimerais vous présenter quelqu'un.
Voici Jomny.
C'est « Jonny » mais écrit accidentellement avec un « m »,
si vous vous le demandiez,
car nous ne sommes pas parfaits.
Jomny est un extraterrestre
qui a été envoyé sur Terre avec pour mission d'étudier les humains.
Jomny se sent perdu, seul et loin de chez lui,
et je pense que nous avons tous ressenti cela.
En tout cas, moi oui.
J'ai écrit cette histoire sur cet extraterrestre
à un moment de ma vie où je me sentais comme un étranger.
Je venais d'emménager à Cambridge et de commencer un doctorat au MIT,
je me sentais intimidé, isolé
et je n'avais pas l'impression d'être à ma place.
Mais j'avais une sorte de planche de salut.
Voyez-vous, pendant des années et des années, j'ai écrit des blagues,
je les ai partagées sur les réseaux sociaux
et j'ai découvert que je me tournais de plus en plus vers cela.
Pour beaucoup de gens, Internet peut sembler être un endroit solitaire.
Il peut ressembler à cela,
un énorme vide, vaste et infini
où vous criez sans cesse mais personne ne vous écoute jamais.
Mais j'ai trouvé du réconfort à parler dans le vide.
J'ai découvert qu'en partageant mes sentiments avec le vide,
le vide a fini par me répondre.
Il s'avère que le vide n'est pas du tout cette étendue solitaire infinie
mais qu'il est plein de toutes sortes de personnes
également tournées vers lui et voulant également être entendues.
Plein de mauvaises choses sont venues des réseaux sociaux.
Je n'essaye pas de discuter cela.
Être en ligne à n'importe quel moment, c'est ressentir tellement de tristesse,
de colère et de violence.
Cela peut sembler être la fin du monde.
Pourtant en même temps, je suis partagé
car je ne peux pas nier le fait que tant de mes amis les plus proches
sont des gens que j'ai rencontrés en ligne.
Je pense que c'est partiellement du fait de cette nature confessionnelle
qu'ont les réseaux sociaux.
Il peut sembler que vous écrivez dans ce journal personnel, intime
qui est totalement privé,
pourtant en même temps vous voulez que tout le monde le lise.
Je crois qu'une partie de cela, la joie dans cela,
est que nous pouvons vivre les choses du point de vue de gens
qui sont complètement différents de nous
et parfois, c'est une bonne chose.
Par exemple, quand j'ai rejoint Twitter,
j'ai découvert que tant de personnes que je suivais
parlaient de santé mentale et suivaient une thérapie
de façons qui n'avaient aucun des stigmates récurrents
quand nous parlons de ces sujets en personne.
A travers elles, la conversation sur la santé mentale a été normalisée
et cela m'a aidé à réaliser que suivre une thérapie était une chose
qui m'aiderait également.
Pour beaucoup de gens,
cela semble être une idée effrayante de parler de tous ces sujets
si publiquement et ouvertement sur internet.
J'ai l'impression que beaucoup de gens pensent que c'est énorme et effrayant
d'être en ligne si vous n'êtes pas déjà parfaitement et complètement constitué.
Mais je pense qu'Internet peut être un très bon lieu où ne pas savoir
et je pense que nous pouvons aborder cela avec enthousiasme
car à mes yeux, il est important de partager vos imperfections,
vos incertitudes et vos vulnérabilités
avec d'autres gens.
(Rires)
Quand quelqu'un partage le fait qu'il se sent triste, effrayé
ou seul, par exemple,
cela me fait me sentir moins seul,
pas en me débarrassant de ma solitude,
mais en me montrant que je ne suis pas seul
à me sentir seul.
En tant qu'écrivain et artiste,
cela m'importe de faire de ce réconfort d'être vulnérable
quelque chose de commun, que nous pouvons partager avec l'autre.
Je suis enthousiaste à l'idée d'externaliser l'interne,
de parler de ces sentiments personnels invisibles
pour lesquels je n'ai pas de mots,
de les mettre en lumière, d'y mettre des mots
et de les partager avec d'autres gens
dans l'espoir que cela les aide à trouver les mots pour leurs émotions.
Je sais que cela semble être considérable,
mais ce qui m'intéresse est de mettre toutes ces choses
dans de petits ensembles abordables,
car quand nous pouvons les cacher dans ces plus petits éléments,
elles sont plus faciles à aborder et plus amusantes.
Je pense que cela peut nous aider à voir notre humanité commune.
Parfois, cela prend la forme d'une nouvelle,
parfois, cela prend la forme d'un petit livre d'illustrations.
Et parfois, cela prend la forme
d'une blague idiote que je lance sur Internet.
Par exemple, il y a quelques mois, j'ai posté cette idée pour une appli
de service de promenade de chien
où un chien vient à votre porte et vous devez sortir de chez vous
et aller faire une promenade.
(Rires)
S'il y a des développeurs d'applis ici,
venez me voir après mon intervention.
Ou j'aime partager qu'à chaque fois que je suis nerveux
pour l'envoi d'un mail,
quand je signe « Bien à vous »,
c'est « J'essaye de bien faire » en court,
qui est « S'il vous plaît, ne me haïssez pas,
je promets que j'essaye de bien faire ! » en court.
Ou ma réponse à la question classique,
si je pouvais dîner avec quiconque, mort ou en vie, je le ferais.
Je me sens très seul.
(Rires)
J'ai découvert que quand je postais de telles choses en ligne,
la réaction était très similaire.
Les gens se réunissent pour en rire,
pour partager ce sentiment,
puis se dissipent tout aussi vite.
(Rires)
Oui, me laissant de nouveau seul.
Mais je pense que parfois,
ces petits rassemblements peuvent être pleins de sens.
Par exemple, quand j'ai fini mon école d'architecture
et ai déménagé à Cambridge,
j'ai posté cette question :
« Avec combien de gens dans votre vie
avez-vous déjà eu votre dernière conversation ? »
Je pensais à mes amis qui avaient déménagé
dans d'autres villes, voire d'autres pays,
et combien il m'était difficile de garder le contact avec eux.
Mais d'autres gens ont répondu et partagé leur propre vécu.
Quelqu'un a parlé d'un parent avec qui il avait eu une querelle.
Quelqu'un a parlé d'un être cher qui était décédé
rapidement et soudainement.
Quelqu'un d'autre a parlé de ses amis d'école
qui avaient aussi déménagé.
Puis quelque chose de très beau s'est produit,
au lieu de ne répondre qu'à moi,
les gens se sont répondu les uns aux autres,
ils ont commencé à se parler, à partager leurs vécus,
à se réconforter
et à s'encourager à prendre contact avec cet ami
à qui ils ne parlaient plus
ou à ce parent avec qui ils s'étaient querellés.
Finalement, nous avons eu cette toute petite communauté.
C'était comme un groupe de soutien
composé de toutes sortes de gens se réunissant.
Je pense qu'à chaque fois que nous mettons quelque chose en ligne,
à chaque fois, il y a une chance
que ces toutes petites communautés se forment.
Il y a une chance que toutes formes de créatures différentes
se réunissent et se rassemblent.
Parfois, dans la boue d'Internet,
vous trouvez un esprit analogue.
Parfois, c'est en lisant les réponses,
les commentaires et en trouvant une réponse particulièrement gentille,
révélatrice ou amusante.
Parfois, c'est en suivant quelqu'un
et en voyant qu'il vous suit déjà.
Parfois, c'est en regardant quelqu'un que vous connaissez dans la vie,
en voyant ce que vous écrivez et ce qu'il écrit,
en réalisant que vous partagez tant d'intérêts communs
et cela le rapproche de vous.
Parfois, si vous êtes chanceux,
vous rencontrez un autre extra-terrestre.
[quand deux extraterrestres se trouvent dans un lieu étrange,
on se sent plus chez soi]
Mais je suis aussi inquiet, car nous le savons,
en général, Internet ne nous donne pas ce sentiment.
Nous savons qu'en général,
Internet semble être un lieu où nous nous méprenons sur les autres,
où nous entrons en conflit les uns avec les autres,
où il y a toutes sortes d'incohérences, de cris et de hurlements
et qu'il semble que c'en soit trop.
Cela ressemble à du chaos
et j'ignore comment séparer le mauvais du bon,
car comme nous le savons et l'avons vu,
le mauvais peut vraiment nous faire beaucoup de mal.
Il me semble que les plateformes utilisées pour occuper ces espaces en ligne
ont été conçues, volontairement ou non,
pour autoriser le harcèlement et les abus, répandre les fausses informations,
favoriser la haine, les discours haineux et la violence qui en découle
et il semble qu'aucune de nos plateformes actuelles
n'en fasse assez pour remédier et arranger cela.
Et pourtant, probablement malheureusement,
je suis, comme tant d'autres, toujours attiré par ces espaces en ligne,
car parfois il semble que c'est là que tout le monde est.
Je me sens idiot
et bête parfois
d'apprécier ces petits moments de contact humain en ces temps.
Mais j'ai toujours agi dans l'idée
que ces petits moments d'humanité ne sont pas superflus.
Ce ne sont pas des retraites face au monde,
mais les raisons pour lesquelles nous venons en ces espaces.
Ils sont importants, vitaux, ils affirment et nous donnent vie.
Ce sont ces petits sanctuaires temporaires
qui nous montrent que nous ne sommes pas aussi seuls que nous le pensons.
Alors même si la vie est dure, que tout le monde est triste
et nous mourons tous un jour --
[la vie est dure. tout le monde est triste.
on va tous mourir, mais j'ai déjà acheté ce château gonflable
alors tu vas enlever T chaussures ou pas]
Je crois que le château gonflable métaphorique dans ce cas,
ce sont nos relations et nos liens avec d'autres personnes.
Un soir,
alors que je me sentais particulièrement triste et désespéré,
j'ai crié dans le vide,
dans l'obscurité solitaire.
J'ai dit : « Arrivé là, se connecter aux réseaux sociaux,
c'est comme tenir la main de quelqu'un à l'autre bout du monde. »
Cette fois-là, au lieu que le vide me réponde,
des gens sont arrivés,
ont commencé à me répondre, à se parler entre eux
et lentement, cette toute petite communauté s'est formée.
Tout le monde s'est réuni pour se tenir la main.
En ces temps dangereux et incertains,
au milieu de tout cela,
je pense que la seule chose à laquelle nous pouvons nous tenir,
ce sont les autres.
Je sais que c'est une petite chose faite de petits moments,
mais je crois que c'est un tout petit rayon de lumière
dans toute cette obscurité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)